a bit now about bangladesh's situation
with corvette 19 the country will
implement a strict lockdown from
thursday
to tackle rapidly rising infections now
initially planned for a week it comes
after a surge in cases
particularly in areas bordering india
the delta variant has run rampant here
and the government wants to avoid a
repeat of the devastation it caused in
india
[Music]
the covert 19 crisis is pushing this
hospital near bangladesh's border with
india
to its limit relatives desperate to
secure medical care
and oxygen for their loved ones
the important issue with the patients
we're currently seeing is their oxygen
saturation levels
they can't be managed properly with only
oxygen cylinder concentrators
and if we can't provide them with a
central oxygen line
god forbid the casualties may increase
[Music]
more than 14 000 people have died in
bangladesh since march
last year and daily infections are
currently skyrocketing
after the pandemic hit a devastating
peak in india in
april deaths began to rise in bangladesh
the border between the two countries was
shut but people continued to cross
illegally prompting new infections and
fatalities
the virus is now raging through smaller
towns and villages in the border regions
[Music]
by making the tests free we can now
locate the covert positive population
people from the villages are coming to
get tested and it's proving the virus
has spread significantly in the villages
the surging cases have pushed the
government to double down
restrictions at a partial shutdown began
in phases on monday
leading to a rush of migrant workers to
flee the capital dhaka
as of this thursday all economic
activity will be halted
an astringent nationwide lockdown will
kick in
but will it be enough to combat the
delta variant
and a lack of vaccines one million doses
of china's sino-farm vaccine recently
arrived in bangladesh
but it's still waiting for 20 million
astrazeneca doses from
india and for two and a half million
doses of the moderna vaccine from the us
before those arrive mass vaccinations
cannot begin
you